first we start with breaking news on the
strip tonight
we thank you so much for joining us
tonight at 11 o'clock i'm
sasha loftis two people were shot at
circus circus this evening
you can see this is video from the scene
here sent
by a viewer we will of course have more
on this
we do have madison kimbrough live on the
scene with the latest on what is
happening there right now madison
yeah that's correct sasha we're told by
metro police that they received a call
about a possible shooting
around 7 30 this evening now take a look
at the video
that we shot earlier where you can see
police arrived they found two people
shot on scene
they were immediately rushed to umc but
are currently in stable condition
people staying in the hotel are shaken
up
we weren't in there we had left to go to
dinner
and then we came back and i saw people
in tears crying
this should be a family area where all
these kids play
and to know that people are out there
just you know killing people
it's not ok
as of now we don't know what led up to
the incident but police do have someone
in custody
police are said to be in this area for
several hours so if you make your way
towards circus circus area please be
careful live at circus circus madison
kimbrough 8 news now